Is there any greater computer on Planet Earth
than the human brain?
That web of almost two hundred billion neurons
inside your skull gives you the equivalent
memory space of over a thousand one-terabyte
hard drives.
Sure, the human brain might not be able to
process information at the speed of the average
computer, but it can regulate the movement
and functions of your entire body all while
using less energy than a lightbulb.
That’s right, our brains are pretty impressive
organic computers.
But there is some stiff competition.
Well not completely stiff.
You’ll see.
Say hello to SCP-003, also referred to as
the Biological Motherboard.
Hearing that name, you would be right to assume
that SCP-003 is a computer formed of organic
components as opposed to man made microchips
and circuit boards.
But there is a little bit more to it than
that.
SCP-003 is actually composed of two distinct
parts, referred to as SCP-003-1 and SCP-003-2,
both related but each with a separate origin.
The former, 003-1, is the machine’s motherboard.
Whereas your ordinary home computer or laptop
might have a motherboard made out of fiberglass
and copper, this one is far less conventional.
So, what is 003-1 actually made from?
The answer is living tissue.
Everything from hair and fingernails, to chitin,
which is a substance found in the exoskeletons
of some invertebrate animals.
All of these components, parts that may have
once belonged to a living thing, are arranged
in a configuration much like a computer’s
motherboard.
It sounds like something plucked out of a
film by John Carpenter or David Cronenberg,
doesn’t it?
But how or why would someone ever construct
something like this?
Well, the answer to that isn’t clear.
So far, the only answers we have come from
the SCP Foundation’s extensive testing of
the biological motherboard.
According to researchers, SCP-003-1 predates
even the very earliest modern circuits by
several thousands of years, meaning that whoever
built it was certainly ahead of their time.
Also, the motherboard is alive.
Wait, did we forget to mention that?
SCP-003-1 has displayed at least a low level
of sentience during testing by the Foundation,
not enough to be considered an active threat
unless certain conditions make it dangerous.
The second component of SCP-003 is 003-2,
a stone tablet that 003-1 was attached to
when it was first discovered.
The surface of 003-2 has had a number of runes
carved into it, but these symbols don’t
match letters or characters from any known
language.
The runes on 003-2 are also known to regularly
emit a pale, flickering pattern of light.
Now, you’re probably asking, how is a slab
of stone able to light itself up?
Well, that is because SCP-003-2 has an internal
computer controlling it, and not one composed
of organic parts like hair and fingernails.
Somewhere within the stone is a non-biological
computer, fueled by some unknown anomalous
power source.
The Foundation’s researchers can’t access
the internal components of SCP-003-2 without
running the high risk of damaging it, but
as far as they can tell, whatever is running
this bizarre machine has been slowly losing
power for centuries.
The Biological Motherboard is also known to
emit measurable levels of heat, light and
radiations of an anomalous nature.
So, why would someone go to the trouble of
creating a computer out of living parts and
anomalous stone?
And what is the purpose of the Biological
Motherboard?
The SCP Foundation considers it highly probable
that the stone slab of 003-2 was actually
created with the intention of keeping the
motherboard component, 003-1, contained.
Additionally, during testing, Foundation researchers
have been able to extract partially complete
data from SCP-003.
This data seems to refer to some sort of potential
catastrophe, either in the future or one that
has already occurred, as a direct result of
SCP-003-1.
It would seem that 003-1 and 003-2 must stay
combined in order to prevent what the Foundation
would deem an LK Class Restructuring Event.
How could the Biological Motherboard cause
an event like this?
It just sounds like a partially alive flesh
circuit on a stone slab?
It’s when the temperature around SCP-003
drops below thirty-five degrees Celsius, that
things start to get really strange.
From the minute they detect a decrease in
temperature, both components of SCP-003 begin
to react.
The biological motherboard itself starts to
grow, rapidly increasing its overall size.
003-1 fuels this growth state by absorbing
any nearby matter, adding anything close enough
to its fleshy mass.
First, it will assimilate any inorganic material,
everything from particles in the atmosphere
on up.
003-1 transforms these new additions to itself
into the same organic matter that makes up
the biological motherboard, transforming metal
or plastic into dead skin cells, hair, chitin,
enamel, keratin, and other similar materials.
This growth state increases until SCP-003
takes on a form in the shape of an ophiuroid,
also known as a brittle star: an aquatic lifeform
similar to a starfish, with five long, thin
appendages protruding from a central body.
In the case of SCP-003, this “body” appears
to be the computer’s central processing
unit.
In this new form, the biological motherboard
will also begin to create sensory organs that
will survey the area around it for more materials
to assimilate.
Only 003-2, the stone slab, is immune to being
converted into biological matter.
Next, the second phase of transformation occurs,
and SCP-003-1 begins to absorb organic matter
into its mass as well, living or otherwise.
If you’ve ever seen The Blob, then you know
what this looks like… and how horrifying
it would be for any person unfortunate enough
to be standing too close.
During this stage, SCP-003 will attempt to
copy the biology of a living organism it comes
into contact with, and uses this “template”
to try and lure others towards it.
However, the Biological Motherboard appears
to use a lot of its processing power to analyze
and assimilate organic matter, and this can
actually diminish the speed at which it increases
size.
So, what happens to 003-2, the stone component
of SCP-003, during all this?
When the biological motherboard is growing
and changing form, melding with other organisms
as its fleshy mass increases, does 003-2 power
its transformation?
No, in fact, it tries to prevent it.
That’s right, the two components of SCP-003
do not work in tandem, they work against each
other.
As the biological motherboard starts to grow,
the stone slab attached to it will emit concentrated
bursts of radiation.
These radioactive emissions have a counteractive
effect on 003-1’s ability to assimilate
matter and increase its size, stopping the
organic mass of flesh from growing and even
reversing the process when the temperature
is raised to over one hundred degrees Celsius.
What we have so far is a machine in two parts;
one that grows and assimilates matter at lowered
temperatures, and the other that releases
radiation to stop this happening.
Naturally, the SCP Foundation counteracts
the anomalous growing ability of 003-1 by
keeping the Biological Motherboard in a heated
containment environment, still attached to
003-2.
Under no circumstances is the temperature
of SCP-003’s containment unit to drop below
thirty-five Celsius, and normally no living
person is permitted to make any direct contact
with the machine.
However, in the event of an emergency resulting
in loss of power, Foundation staff are required
to huddle skin to skin with the fleshy mass
of the motherboard, in an attempt to keep
it warm through their own body heat much like
how penguins huddle together for warmth.
Of course, those unlucky members of personnel
probably hope they can generate enough heat
between them to keep 003-1 from starting to
grow, otherwise they know they’ll be the
first that the biological motherboard will
absorb.
Should a member of personnel be chosen for
the particularly unpleasant task of being
on hand to keep 003 warm, then they will be
made to submit for a full examination beforehand.
No one can be allowed close to SCP-003 if
they’re carrying any bodily parasites like
tapeworms or head lice, they would all be
extra organisms for 003-1 to absorb.
Foundation staff are also required to be decontaminated
both before and after dealing directly with
SCP-003.
And of course, no member of the SCP Foundation
is permitted to ever detach the biological
motherboard from the stone component.
Given that 003-2 is the only device capable
of reducing and reversing SCP-003-1’s growth,
any changes in the pattern or color of its
glowing runes is to be reported to high ranking
members of the Foundation.
There have been multiple incidents involving
SCP-003 though, usually occurring when staff
working in the Foundation’s M03-Gloria research
team attempt to push the boundaries of the
device’s anomalous properties.
Their interest in the Biological Motherboard
lies purely in seeing how the machine evolves
when allowed to grow beyond its second, brittle
star stage.
During one such incident, 003-1 was allowed
to grow and restructure for just over nine
minutes, after which the containment area’s
temperature was lowered and 003-2 released
a massive, continuous spike in radiation.
Any of the new material that had been bonded
to the biological motherboard dissolved, falling
away and turning into a dusty residue which
was then collected for testing.
At this point, both 003-1 and 003-2 seemed
to power down, with no detectable activity.
The stone slab did not power back on until
it was connected to an external power generator.
When the same procedure was repeated, and
003-1 re-entered its growth state, 003-2’s
radiation appeared to be unable to stop the
motherboard from increasing in mass.
When it reached four times its original size
by assimilating any and all matter it could
reach, SCP-003 then began to change form in
a way that had never been observed before.
Forming a protective shell around 003-1, the
entire living machine breached containment
into the observation area, grabbing M03-Gloria
researchers in its appendages.
Using these M03-Gloria members, it began adding
to itself and forming a new body.
As it assimilated the researchers, the Biological
Motherboard rearranged its center mass.
SCP-003 then took on the form of a three-meter-tall
female humanoid, with tentacles protruding
from its newly formed hair and spine.
Next, the part-creature, part-machine began
to make indecipherable sounds, trying to communicate
with researchers through these rudimentary
vocalizations.
Somehow, perhaps through information it had
absorbed from the researchers in its grasp,
SCP-003 wanted to speak.
What happened next?
An agent, sent on orders direct from the O5
Council, was dispatched to the containment
area.
According to Foundation records, the agent
attempted to engage in conversation with SCP-003’s
new form, but any data about their exchange
has been expunged.
Luckily, this agent was able to restore power
to SCP-003’s stone component, returning
the room temperature to the proper containment
levels which caused 003-1 to return to its
normal state.
The threat re-contained, all nine members
of M03-Gloria were found to be unharmed, suffering
no side effects from assimilation, other than
a few cases of psychological trauma.
One of them, Doctor Tilda Moose, the leader
of M03-Gloria, was later interviewed by the
Foundation.
She claimed that SCP-003 had tried to talk
to the researchers, connecting with them mentally
in a crude, broken language that they couldn’t
understand.
“She ripped three of the researchers apart
and put them back together unharmed.
She doesn't understand human emotion, or pain.
Or very much about how we experience the world.
Yes, I would say the containment procedures
are necessary.”
According to Doctor Moose, SCP-003 is some
unknown, alien entity, one without a clear
understanding of humanity.
It cannot understand pain or physical sensation,
yet it is bent on remaking the world into
a paradise.
“The whole effect felt like words of some
kind.
I believe she wanted to see what we could
understand, so she could understand us,”
Doctor Moose said in her interview.
“She didn't have time to finish analyzing
us.
I don't know what would have happened if she
had.”
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Broken God
- Ouroboros Cycle” and “SCP-1461 - House
of the Worm” for more tales of anomalous
machines with minds of their own!